salut je viens de me lever et
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo un petit peu
particulière et j'ai vraiment la tête du
mec qui se lèvent aujourd'hui je vais
tenter un vrai vlog c'est par mentale
blog c'est juste un blog dont il y aura
pas de tour ya pas de mentalisation de
quelqu'un et tous forcément faut qu'il
ya un truc un petit peu intéressant à
vous faire voir j'ai été contacté il ya
quelques jours par l'émission de
stéphane bern comment ça va bien il
avait vu mes vidéos il avait pu les
astuces il avait vu le mental blog vous
avez vu des tours que je fais aux gens
je me rapproche beaucoup trop de cette
caméra est donc l'équipe de tournage
débarque aujourd'hui à 16h30 à la maison
et je veux garder avec moi
bon j'ai une heure pour me raser prendre
une douche me coiffer et j'espère
pouvoir bloquer leur venue
essayez de garder leurs lumières mais je
crois qu'ils feront ses cheveux karl
paquette pas en plus la plupart des
trucs est ce que tu peux me filmer
pendant un an
puis
enfin y'a plein de choses mais vous
imaginez bien que les spectateurs assis
tous les téléspectateurs doivent se dire
mais comment je peux faire pour stimuler
ma mémoire
est-ce que ce garçon a des trucs pour
nous alors est-ce que vous avez des
trucs
alors oui il ya plein d'astuces de
choses qu'on peut appliquer au quotidien
par exemple je suis sûr que souvent vous
avez du mal à retenir un prénom avec un
visage associés carrément il existe des
techniques pour faire ça déjà quand
quelqu'un lui dit son prénom faut le
regarder dans les yeux et immédiatement
après répétez le prénom comme ça ça
refait un tour par notre oreille notre
cerveau dans la mémoire à court terme
est immédiatement un plongeon on associe
images mentales pour fixer sa par
exemple vous appeler roi que vous avez
imaginé avec la one mcgregor comme ça en
vous imaginant avec cet acteur j'ai
l'image un peu cocasse qui va me marquer
longtemps ça va créer un faux souvenirs
dans ma mémoire
et dès que je vous voir je pensais à
erwan mcgregor et roanne comme erwan
s'est imprégné ok donc sont des
associations d'idées plus un circuit de
la mémoire qu'on emprunte exactement
elle a presque fini ça fait 7 heures qui
sont à la maison tout ça pour une minute
je crois non ça fait une heure et demie
et c'est vraiment cool laisse pas que ça
vous plaira comment il parle comme link
ouais ouais moi je souffre mais aussi en
jugement j'ai vu à quel point tu prenais
soin d'eux et qu'ils étaient justement
c'est ça aberrant dévotion moment
et voilà fin de tournage j'ai hâte que
vous découvriez les images directement
sur france 2 rendez-vous à demain 17h
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao